le coup de coeur du cinéma les yeux
d'elsa cette semaine c'est une
projection de film et un concert qui
aura lieu le 4 mars
ici au cinéma les yeux d'elsa et ça se
passe dans le cadre du festival électro
chic versailles touch un festival
co-organisé par
la communauté d'agglomération de
versailles grand parc il ya plusieurs
événements du 2 au 4 mars sur autour de
versailles nous on accueille un
événement c'est à dire le concert d'un
groupe qui s'appelle anyways un groupe
de pop rock électro qui se produira sur
la scène derrière moi et juste après ce
concert on présentera un film qui est
rarement vu au cinéma qui s'appelle
interstella 5 5 5 5
the secretstory aux star system c'est un
film un peu particulier parce que il est
composé que de clips de l'album
discovery de daft punk alors pour ceux
qui s'en souviennent daft punk tout le
monde le sait grand groupe français
d'électro en 2001 ils sortent discovery
qui est vendu par une série de clips qui
sont des clips fabriqué en animation une
animation qui ressemblent pour les plus
anciens d'entre nous le saurons à
albator à ce genre de dessin animé là
des années 80 et puis alors que l'album
est déjà vendu tout à coup sûr un film
et on se rend compte que tous ses clips
sont quand on les assemble dans un
certain ordre sont un long métrage une
seule histoire de 1h eh bien c'est ce
long métrage qu'on vous propose de voir
ici le samedi 4 mars à partir de 20h30
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
n'hésitez pas à chercher les
renseignements il suffit de taper
festival électro chic et vous trouverez
tout ce qu'il vous faut